[Musique]
bienvenue chez le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire la fameuse tribune des
généraux n'a pas fini de créer la
polémique publié d'abord sur place
d'armes elle a ensuite été relayée par
valeurs actuelles le 21 avril 60 ans
jour pour jour après le putsch des
généraux d'alger à hasard m'a dit le
directeur de valeurs actuelles
marine le pen a été la première à réagir
puis jean luc mélenchon et enfin
florence parly la ministre des armées au
bout de cinq jours alors est elle si
grave que ça cette tribune tout le monde
n'est pas d'accord
est-ce qu'il s'agit d'un appel au putsch
c'est ce que l'on va voir
et l'on regarderait également le sondage
harris interactive pour lci qui semble
indiquer qu'une majorité de français
serait d'accord avec son contenu et que
près d'un français sur deux penseraient
que l'armée doit intervenir pour
garantir l'ordre
même sans être sollicité par le
gouvernement alors nous avons invité
jean-pierre fabre bernadac c'est vous
qui est à l'origine de la tribu des
généraux on l'appelle la tribune et
généraux mais c'est vous qui l'avait
écrite vous avez quitté l'armée en 1987
après être passé par l'infanterie et la
gendarmerie mobile où vous aviez le
grade de capitaine vous êtes devenu
responsable de la sécurité d'un groupe
industriel vous avez également dirigé le
service d'ordre du front national le dps
dans les années 90 depuis vous publier
des livres comme les strings de l'armée
rouge chez l'harmattan sur les femmes
russes en france où les damnés de la
france qui vient de paraître aux
éditions de paris
un pamphlet contre la censure dont sont
victimes je vous cite ceux qui refusent
la pensée unique alors en deux mots jean
pierre fabre dermo bernadac
qu'est ce que vous avez voulu dire dans
cette tribune
d'abord la prod la tribune c'est un
constat c'est un constat de mon pays tel
que je le vois c'est un constat qui peut
devenir tragique je ne dis pas qu'il
l'est aujourd'hui ou traumatiques
je dis simplement que je suis non pas un
lanceur dallaire mais un sonneur de toc
ça parce qu'aujourd'hui je pense qu'on
est dans une situation assez terrible et
quels sont les gens pour moi qu'est ce
qu'elle est le personnel qui était à
même de
de comprendre souci si ce n'est des gens
qui ont servi leur pays qui ont servi le
drapeau et qui par conséquent a été à
même de voir ça si ces gens n'avaient
pas répondu si nous n'avions pas comme
aujourd'hui 25 mille réponses et 25 me
signature je pense que je me serais
trompé mais je crois que ce qui se passe
actuellement montre que l'armée a bien
compris ce problème et je pense que
l'armée a un côté fer de lance dans la
mesure où le pays la notion de patrie et
nous est chevillée au corps
voilà jean yves camus vous êtes
politologue spécialiste de l'extrême
droite chercheur associé à l'iris vous
dirigez l'observatoire des radicalités
politique de la fondation jean jaurès
depuis 2014 est auteur de nombreux
livres sur le sujet qui nous occupe le
dernier c'est les droites extrêmes en
europe qui est paru aux éditions du
seuil coécrit avec nicolas lebourg
comment vous l'avez donné analysez-vous
cette tribune alors précisément je suis
pas sûr que cette tribu sa sortie des
sujets qui sont censés m'occuper parce
qu'elle n'a pas grand chose à voir avec
avec l'extrême droite traditionnelle
c'est effectivement une tribune est
signée par des militaires pour la
plupart du cadre de réserve qui
expriment des constats je trouve qu'il
ya dans cette tribu d'une phrase qui est
assez regrettable et qui laisse entendre
que l'armée d'actifs pourraient
intervenir sans avoir été sollicité par
le président de la république dans le
cadre qui est prévu par la constitution
mais pour le reste on peut effectivement
discuter du contenu moi la seule chose
que je remarque c'est que finalement
sans contester une seule seconde que les
militaires soient porteur d'un idéal
patriotique comme valeur daigné cet
idéal patriotique il existe aussi chez
nombre d'électeurs nous en fait partie
et le dernier mot dans tout cela face au
constat que vous dansiez l'instant un
constat terrible dites vous c'est les
électeurs qui l'ont caroline galak
terros vous êtes géopolitologue
directrice du think tank géo pragma qui
voudraient repenser l'action stratégique
de la france vous tenez un blog intitulé
bouger les lignes vous êtes l'auteur de
vers à nouveau yalta paru aux éditions
cij est vous l'avez analyser comment le
texte de cette tribune
écoutez moi je n'ai pas du tout je
dirais que c'est l'appel au putsch qui
fait pschitt quoi c'est à dire c'est une
temps on a fait une tempête dans un
verre d'eau et on a instrumentalisé
cette tribune qui est en fait un constat
d'alert que qu'énormément de gens font
qui n'a rien d'un scoop ou de quelque
chose de radicalement nouveau et
immédiatement il ya une
instrumentalisation politique sur tous
les bords de tous les bords que ce soit
les autorités en place que ce soit bien
sûr à gauche à l'extrême droite
donc malheureusement en fait pour moi
cette tribune elle est très simple je ne
l'aurais pas écrite comme ça parce que
je pense que j'aurai des mines et cette
instrumentalisation dans le contexte
politique qui est le nôtre actuellement
mais elle ne fait que dire des évidences
en fait sur l'état malheureux de la
sécurité et aussi de l'unité de notre
pays et l alerte sur un scénario qui
n'est pas du tout un appel à la sédition
enfin moi je n'ai pas du tout lui comme
ça s'éteint c'est au contraire un
scénario qui est tout à fait prévu qui
est anticipée qui est planifiée qui est
réfléchie par les armées et sur lequel
j'espère qu'on reviendra qui prévoit que
dans certaines circonstances
et bien oui là les forces armées peuvent
être amenés à conquérir naturellement à
la demande du pouvoir politique
on est on est dans un état de droit
c'est le président quel chef des armées
mais il peut malheureusement si un
certain nombre suscite toutes les autres
forces des catégories précédentes ne
peuvent plus faire leur travail ou sont
débordés il peut intervenants des aux
forces armées d'intervenir c'est pour
moi c'est ça qui a été
c'était sale alerte c'est à dire si on
ne fait rien on pourra arriver un
scénario où malheureusement il faudrait
en arriver à ce niveau-là d'intervention
david guiraud vous êtes porte-parole
jeunesse de la france à soubise qui a
été assez promptes à réagir contre la
tribune vous êtes directeur de cabinet
d'eric coquerel le député français
soumise de seine saint denis
j'avais pas qu'on était qu'il y avait un
cabinet quand on était député vous vous
l'analysez comment cette tribune david
pour soi écoutez c'est assez simple
c'est une tribune qui est mené par des
militants d'extrême droite
parce que quand on est par exemple la
personne quand nous avons en face de
nous qui assume d'avoir fait le service
d'ordre du front national c'est-à-dire
quand même le service d'ordre d'un homme
jean marie le pen qui considérait que
les chambres à gaz étaient un détail de
l'histoire je suis désolé c'est une
tribune de militants d'extrême droite on
en a beaucoup des gens qui ont été
candidats très récemment pour le front
pour le rassemblement national
vous en avez d'autres qui sont membres
de groupes encore plus dangereux je
pense à monsieur martinez et toute une
galaxie de gens d'extrême droite donc
c'est une opération d'extrême droite
mais qui ne représentent ni les
militaires parce que je rappelle qu'à ce
jour il ya vingt-trois mille personnes
qui ont signé la tribune essentiellement
des retraités
je pense qu'on serait bien en peine de
savoir si c'est ailleurs que des
militaires retraités qui ont signé c'est
à dire même pas 2 % des militaires
retraités de ce pays est le but de cette
tribune c'est quoi c'est de faire croire
que les militaires représenterait un
malaise ou ou d'accréditer des idées
d'extrême droite mais attendez mais les
militaires ils peuvent voter mais ils
sont pas tous d'accord pour procéder
comme ça ils sont pas tous d'accord sur
ce constat là et ils sont encore moins
d'accord pour qu'on salisse l'image de
l'armée en la faisant intervenir de
cette manière là de manière aussi
abrupte et et barbare dans le débat
public ce n'est pas le rôle des
militaires ça et donc voilà on se
retrouve en face maintenant d'un débat
public qui a été menée par des militants
d'extrême droite
comme si ces idées là était crédible
comme si elle représentait ce que peut
penser le parti de la france non le
contenu de cette tribune par exemple est
raciste quand on parle des ordres de
vente des hordes de beaulieu part
d'hommes en fait les habitants de
banlieue ne sont pas des animaux
donc vous voyez on
il y à une opération une machination là
dedans je ne sais pas à quel point
marine le pen a trempé là dedans il y
avait beaucoup de ses anciens candidats
mais une opération qui vise à
crédibiliser toujours plus une parole
d'extrême droite dans la société c'est
aussi pour ça qu'on s'y opposent jean
pierre fabre bernadac
est-ce que tu une tribune d'extrême
droite écoutez je vais vous dire je ne
sais pas si c'est une tribune d'extrême
droite mais je voudrais dire à monsieur
quelque chose dans le sauvage qu'il y a
eu de nous nous avons 58 % des français
qui sont d'accord avec nous est ce que
ce monsieur sait combien de gens de la
france insoumise sont d'accord avec nous
mêmes les audits et oui bien sûr je vais
vous parler de ce sondage
donc en fait on a interrogé donnez-moi
le chiffre après on parle du sondage fut
l'accord donné à l'échec c'est
intéressant je suis pas en fait on n'est
pas à l'école donc je vais vous dire ce
sondage qui est très intéressant et le
fait majeur de sondage c'est qu'on
interroge 1600 personnes d'accord parmi
les 1600 personnes interrogées il y en a
un tiers qui savent même pas de quoi on
parle
d'accord et parmi eux il y en a un autre
tir qui voit vaguement de quoi en bas et
un dernier tiers qui s'est précisément
de quoi est l'objet cette tribune c'est
à dire qu'en fait parmi les 1600
personnes qu'on a interrogés c'est à
dire on ne sait même pas d'ailleurs si
c'était un échantillon est représentatif
ou pas on n'a que six cents personnes
qui savent de quoi on parle vous voyez
ce genre d'opération de l'extrême droite
qui est confirmée malheureusement pas
comment dire de 1,3 on plaisante
l'extrême noir alors avoué le décès mais
n'ont pu s'y attendait on va relier à
travers lui c'est moi viendra sur le
tournage on reviendra sur le sec mais
c'est pas moi qui ai fait son match
quand même faudrait pas de dire
n'importe quoi
on reviendra sur le sondage tout à
l'heure parce qu'effectivement il pose
un certain nombre de problèmes mais
terminé jean pierre fabre bernadac
vous étiez un terreau pour vouliez dire
qu'il y avait à septembre des lecteurs
du dudu la france a soumises qui
semblaient d'accord avec vous dont 100
sont en bas alors je vous donnais le il
est le 43 % on n'est même pas loin de la
moitié de la moitié de 50%
donc ça je pense que c'est un signe
c'est un signe de quoi sassine que je
pense que au delà des partis alors voyez
le problème de l'extrême droite on en
parlera
mais au delà des partis il ya un
problème les gens se sentent concernés
par ce que les gens qu'ils soient de la
france insoumise des écologistes du
rassemblement national des républicains
ou deux personnes ces gens là je vais
vous dire quand ils ont la mobylette qui
était piquée en bas de chez eux quand
ils ont leur boîte aux lettres qui est
cassé
quand ils ont à jusqu'à 2 heures du
matin que les bruits ils ont on en marre
c'est pas moi je vais vous dire le grand
problème c'est pas la violence très
forte qu'on l'envoie à la télévision c
c'est cette petite violence insidieuse
constante qui est dans un certain nombre
de cités et cécité malheureusement ces
sites et c'est là où je tiens intervenir
sont déjà du peuple c'est ces gens des
peuples qui sont touchés le plus c'est
pas la grande bourgeoisie elle dans le
xvième elle a moins de problèmes mais
c'est ça et moi ce que je regrette c'est
que les gens de la france est soumise ne
soutiennent pas ça en disant oui c'est
là un problème le premier problème c'est
d'abord tous ces gens qui
malheureusement subissent toutes ces
agressions mais alors permettez moi de
répondre d'abord ces gens que vous
appelez à ces gens c'est très facile de
les citer mais dans votre texte vous les
nommez vous dit que ce sont des hordes
des hordes de banlieue donc je ne sais
pas quel est le degré de respect vous
attacher à ces gens là je vous ai laissé
parler donc j'aimerais finir je ne sais
pas quel est le degré de respect de vous
attacher à ces gens c'est vous vous
instrumentaliser ces questions et vous
êtes en train de nous expliquer qu'en
gros pour des scooters volés des boîtes
aux lettres cassées parce que je
reprends votre expression s'envoyer
l'armée c'est à dire des militaires
armés de fusils à pompe et de famas bas
je suis désolé moi j'suis pas d'accord
pensent qu'on peut régler les choses
autrement parce que votre tribune vise
précisément à dire que puisqu'il ya une
insécurité du quotidien mais c'est pas
le rôle de l'armée de régler insécurité
du quotidien monsieur pardon c'est le
rôle de la police éventuellement on peut
avoir un débat là-dessus mais je refuse
et moi je vous le dis je l'assumé je
refuse de reprendre le terme du débat
avec vous nous parlez de hordes de
banlieue comme si les gens étaient des
animaux alors que vous avez des
départements populaires comme la
seine-saint-denis qui sont qui est le
département le plus pauvre de france
mais 8e contributeur en termes de
protection sociale c'est-à-dire des
départements solidaire où les gens se
lèvent le matin
pour livrer vos colis pour livrer votre
nourriture pour faire tourner vos métro
vautrin et vos services publics
notamment dans le système de santé et
vous la seule le seul mot que vous avez
pour ces gens dans votre tribune c'est
de les traiter de hordes comme si tous
les gamins de ces quartiers étaient
étaient des bêtes sauvages pas pardon
monsieur mais c'est une tribune
d'extrême droite vous négligez les gens
voulaient méprisé voulait salissez
effectivement je ne suis pas d'accord
avec vous pour débattre sur cette base
là ça me paraît évident quand même jean
yves camus vous dites que justement à ce
propos là est ce que c'est une tribune
d'extrême droite de sangliers dire non
tout à l'heure donc je disais la chose
suivante parmi les 24 minutes je crois
vingt-cinq mille signataires aujourd'hui
ils sont trouve certainement qui ont
voté pour le rassemblement national ou
qui s'apprêtent à le faire on sait que
marine le pen a recueilli en 2017 un
pourcentage de voix chez les militaires
qui est supérieur à la moyenne nationale
mais on ne peut pas réduire la totalité
de ses vingt-cinq mille signatures à une
opération de militants du rassemblement
national ce qui moi me gêne dans cette
tribune c'est en fait qu'est les noces
des constats dont on peut effectivement
débattre que par ailleurs david des
roulades il contient un certain nombre
d'expressions extrêmement dépréciatif
qui ne correspondent pas à la situation
parce que l'insécurité au quotidien n
existe pas que dans les banlieues il
existe aussi par exemple dans les
départements ruraux malheureusement et
puis elle existe en général à paris
je l'expérimentent pour ma part dans mon
propre quartier assez quotidiennement et
elle n'est pas le fait de hordes de
banlieue mais la réponse à ce moment là
c'est effectivement en premier lieu la
police et pour que la police intervienne
il faut lui donner des moyens d'une part
et puis il faut également arrêter de
dire que la police est coupable de tous
les maux de la terre et qu'elle le fait
jaillir de la mettre dans une situation
encore plus difficile que celle qu'elle
connaît qui est celle de la pénurie des
effectifs de la pénurie des moyens
matériels qui rendent son intervention
extrêmement difficile mais est ce que
c'est une tribune d'extrême droite alors
le parallèle a été fait tout de suite
avec le putsch d'avril 1961 parce
qu'effectivement valeurs actuelles
décision concertée au hasard du
calendrier la publiait le 21 avril le
site place d'armes ne la publie pas le
21 avril le publie si je me souviens
bien le 14
et puis si on veut véritablement poussé
le parallèle avec le push de 61
on s'aperçoit très vite que ça tient pas
c'est tient pas d'abord parce que quand
on veut véritablement fassi les auteurs
du texte avaient voulu faire un appel
mémorielle au push de 1961 il aurait eu
bien tort parce que ce putsch il a
échoué et il a échoué finalement assez
rapidement le général de gaulle et les
autorités on en eut raison assez vite
parce que même en algérie tout le monde
ne brillait pas parce qu on m paul
personne nombre ayez donc c'est pas
véritablement un exemple à suivre c'est
d'autre moi un exemple à suivre est un
exemple qui à défaut fait référence que
le pousse à a laissé des traces
extrêmement
violente une sorte de plaies ouvertes à
l'intérieur de l'armée
ces 500 ou 600 officiers sous-officiers
qui participent topuz d'avril 61
c'est aux alentours d'un millier
d'officiers et de sous-officiers qu'ils
soient sont condamnés doivent quitter
l'armée soit qu'ils ont dû goûter où
serait pas mal quand même que vous
songez à une reconversion
donc ça véritablement laissé une sorte
de plaignante et je crois que la manière
dont le putsch s'est déroulé la manière
dont il a échoué dans tout ça c'est
terminé
et quand même des gens qui sont passés
au peloton d'exécution ça ne vois là ça
n'incite pas précisément les militaires
à se lancer dans l'aventuré
quand l'armée intervient elle intervient
à la demande du président de la
république ça a été dit dans des
circonstances assez précises on a un
article 16-1-1 article 36 je pense qu'il
faut s'en tenir là celui qui décidera
reçu qu'un jour peut-être et je ne
l'espère pas il est nécessaire d'
enclencher cette procédure c'est le
président de la république et lui seul
car les murs avec terros mais oui bien
sûr le président de la république et le
chef des armées c'est lui qui peut
décider cela ceci dit dire que enfin si
vous voulez il faudrait pas confondre il
faudrait pas s'attacher sent en
permanence sur le messager et oublier le
message le message il est il est très
simple message n'importe qui le gleut
est d'ailleurs le sondage le montre très
bien
n'importe qui a compris que notre pays
est dans un état de dégradation
sécuritaire important
bon ça c'est une chose c'est une
évidence ya pas que les banlieues ya pas
de place bellecour à lyon ccd rodéo
ça n'arrête pas à tous les niveaux donc
que faire
il y a bien sûr des forces de police il
y a des forces de gendarmerie
territoriale il ya des forces de
gendarmerie
mobile il y a la garde nationale mais
quand tout cela il faut pas oublier que
les les forces armées comme les forces
de l'intérieur d'ailleurs sont
organisées il ya déjà des il ya des
plans il ya des scénarios et il est tout
à fait acter enfin il est tout à fait
décidé que dans certaines conditions
si jamais le climat sécuritaire du pays
se dégrade est à un point tel que les
forces de première et deuxième catégorie
c'est à dire plus toutes les forces
civiles c'est-à-dire les forces de
police les forces de gendarmerie
les forces de la garde nationale ne
suffisait pas été débordée étaient
insuffisantes était dépassé et est
inadaptée et bien dans certaines
conditions bien sûr sous la direction du
politique il peut être décidé de faire
appel à des forces terrestres pour
assurer la protection des citoyens
donc si vous voulez je trouve que ce
soit on parle du climat sécuritaire on
prend cette tribune pour ce qu à mon
avis elle est alors évidemment c'est
dans un contexte politique et tout le
monde se jette dessus pour en faire son
miel mais c'est fort dommage
et ça ne règle pas le problème le
problème c'est un constat et c'est que
en fait je pense que ce qui a déplu
foncièrement souverainement au pouvoir
dans cette tribune c'est évidemment
c'est une apostrophe très directe au
pouvoir est une une falaise le doigt sur
la plaie koala play c'est à dire la
faillite de la responsabilité c'est à
dire le fait que l'on laisse faire un
certain nombre de choses pour diverses
raisons
au terme d'un certain nombre de
processus de dégradation de l'autorité
de la responsabilité politique et on
arrive à un point où on se dit mais ça
peut effectivement mal tourné et quand
ça tourne vraiment très très mal et que
les forces classiques ne peuvent plus
rien faire et bien effectivement il est
prévu c'est tout à fait c'est pas c'est
pas vous de décider qui a le droit
d'intervenir ou qui n'a pas le droit
d'intervenir
le politique peut tout à fait faire
appel aux forces armées dans un cadre
très circonscrits à ce qu'évidemment les
modes d'action ne sont pas les mêmes
mais si c'est nécessaire c'est
nécessaire donc après voilà c'est ce qui
compte c'est le diagnostic sécuritaire
qui qui doit être bien fait et surtout
une réaction et une reprise en main en
sécurité de notre pays de notre nation
pour que ça ne ça ne parte pas vraiment
à vau l'eau
david guiraud nous voit bouillir
mais oui parce que parce que vous faites
une erreur en ne voulant pas voir la
qualité des gens qui font cet appel
d'où ils viennent qui ils sont je pense
que vous faites une vraie erreur parce
que vous savez les gens qui appellent un
exemple monsieur martinez sont partis
politiques les volontaires pour la
france et une scission dans son
organisation politique et on a retrouvé
des anciens membres de son parti en
train de projeter un attentat terroriste
intercepté par la dgse en 2018 déjà sa
peau ça devrait déjà posé question dans
l'espace public de petits sont ces gens
là
et le pire le pire c'est que ces gens
persiste et signe dans l'impunité la
plus totale je vous allez sur le site de
monsieur fabre bernadac sur le son site
place d'armes j'ai vu un texte est sorti
a très vite en très peu de temps de
monsieur roland dubois
je vais juste vous citez pour vous
compreniez un petit peu la nature des
échanges que ces genres ont entre eux il
dit je le cite nos soldats ne sont ni
instruit ni entraîner ni armé moralement
pour les services de maintien de l'ordre
qui nous donne quand même une certaine
idée de ce qui va se passer
il continue il y aura des bavures si ils
interviennent
nos chefs d'al savoir donc en fait on a
quelqu'un qui annonce qui va intervenir
et qu'en plus il va je ne sais pas tuer
des gens et borny des gens on sait pas
et il continue à la fin alors il
continue dans ce texte à la fin il dit
et là on entendra le bruit des bottes
mais rassurons-nous ce seront les nôtres
est ce que ça donne vraiment envie de
discuter avec ces gens moi je vous le
dis et je l'assumé non je ne veux pas
discuter climat sécuritaire avec des
gens qui sont persuadés
en gros ils vont faire des bavures et
quel succès comme si c'était normal dans
un pays démocratique sur le constat
sécurité un moyen d un débat je vous dis
pour l'instant je vois une augmentation
une explosion
la fait diversion de la société c'est à
dire pour moi en avant les faits divers
en dire qu'ils s'exposent les chiffres
du ministère de l'intérieur etc ou alors
il se 50 plus où on ne prend plus en
compte il ya effectivement à la fin du
confinement il ya une hausse des
homicides c'est vrai mais enfin les
cambriolages sont en baisse et prakash
santander
il ya énormément de phénomène de société
sur la violence qui sont au ps tous les
statisticiens un peu sérieux vous
distingue l'aube allemand il ya un
problème d'insécurité mais il est
constant dans la société il n'est pas en
explosion comme veulent nous le faire
croire comme les déclinistes et tous les
gens d'extrême qui n'ont pas confiance
en fait dans ce pays et c'est vrai que
la sécurité c'est insupportable je moi
je
je veux bien le concevoir mais comment
vous pouvez imaginer de penser que les
gens qui ont fait cette réunion sont des
gens honnêtes ils vous disent à un
moment il ya un antiracisme je cite le
texte de la tribune
les gens veulent la guerre raciale en
eau les antiracistes veulent la guerre
raciale c'est ça que tu dis que tu es et
dans le même temps si vous avez si vous
allez sur le site de monsieur fabre
bernadac donc place d'armes vous y
trouverez des interviews des textes de
jean comme monsieur bernard lugan
bernard lugan c'est quelqu'un qui est
pour l'apartheid
voilà pour qui en fait il faut séparer
les noirs et les blancs et comment vous
pouvez penser que ces gens sont honnêtes
comment vous pouvez penser que ces gens
n'ont pas un agenda politique est ce que
je trouve dommage
en fait c'est pas tant que ces gens
soient extrêmement extrême droite mais
le problème c'est la complaisance le
manque de recherche
le manque de sérieux de fait d'aller
chercher qui sont les signataires qu'est
ce qui dit ce qu'est ce qui est dit sur
le site de monsieur fabre bernadac où on
a des gens comme alain de benoist qui
font la promotion de l'ethno
différentialisme mais par contre dans
leur tribune ils vont dire que c'est des
antiracistes qui divise la france mais
eux ils trouvent pas de problème
interviewer des gens qui pensent qu'il
faut séparer les noirs et les blancs
dans certains pays bas vous voyez vous
voyez que c'est pas possible en fait
d'avoir le débat sur ces bases là c'est
pas un débat sain et c'est ça moi que je
critique c'est la complaisance des gens
vis-à-vis de de l'identité et des
auteurs de ces tribunes alors réponse de
jean pierre fabre bernadac rapide pelle
mais je vais être obligée vous
inspireront parce qu'il va y avoir une
pause mais je vous donnerai la parole
après alors allez d'accord d'accord
alors écoutez je veux d'abord je vais
vous dire je pense que on parle pas
français tous la même france est en tous
les cas
parce que quand je lis ma tribune comme
jeu
quand j'ai exprimé ma tribune mais alors
c'est pas du tout ce que j'entends avec
ce monsieur qui d'ailleurs n'a qu'un mot
vous savez c'est m le maudit sur
l'épaule il a le n 1 et par conséquent
ces voix là c'est l'extrême droite
c'est donc l'extrême droite c'est le
populisme c'est le fascisme 7 nazisme
selecom concentration mais on
connaissait par coeur et c'est évident
que demain je suis un aux règles
personnage
moi je voudrais dire d'abord un pont ou
une chose on a parlé de hordes on m'a
mis deux fois en cause sur le muhr alors
je vais vous donner la définition du
larousse de hordes la horde c'est un
groupe de personnes causant des dommages
par sa violence point final
je pense qu'on est tout à fait dans le
cadre de ce qui se passe actuellement
dans certaines banlieues et ailleurs que
des banlieues vous avez d'autres vous
avez parlé monsieur camus du problème
rural mais oui mais oui un problème
rural moi je l'étais par exemple n'y a
pas très longtemps j'habitais bergerac
et bien à bergerac il ya un quartier
sensible dit sensible maintenant on
appelle ça comme ça dit sensibles c'est
à dire que cette espèce de de
dégressivité se répand partout et c'est
ça qui est dramatique c'est que ce n'est
plus en effet dans les banlieues de
suburbaines dans les grandes banlieues
suburbaines mais c'est aussi maintenant
dans n'importe quel coin du territoire
français je vous interromps j'en veux à
jean pierre fabre bernadac ont fait la
pause les joueurs donnent la parole
juste après
[Musique]
cela fait plus d'un an maintenant que le
coc vide 19 est apparu dans nos vies
crise sanitaire crise économique comment
tout cela va se terminer aujourd'hui
vous avez de la dette qui est mise vous
avez de la monnaie qui est émise ça pour
camoufler le manque de croissance et
dans dix ans les monnaies seront par
terre qu'on ne peut pas créer de la
croissance en imprimant des billets
comme par magie que vous créez ce sont
des problèmes sociaux le système est
irrémédiablement cas si beaucoup on peut
que après 2008
les les banques auraient pris certaines
leçons or pas du tout aujourd'hui elles
sont exactement dans la même situation
voire pire les banques sont au dessus
des lois
il n'y a aucune réglementation pour elle
la crise du coc vide a simplement révélé
à quel point le système était fragile
[Musique]
en féminines ici des commis tous les
deux à trois jours en france
actuellement
pourquoi il joue ton encore à protéger
totalement les femmes on dit souvent
femmes osé en parler
briser le silence nous savons que
seulement 18 19 % des femmes révèle les
violences qu'elles subissent donc ça
veut dire qu'il ya 80% de femmes qui ne
révèle pas les violences qu'elles
subissent aux forces de sécurité dont
celle qui rêvait il faut vraiment les
croix et les protéger souvent on met
toute la responsabilité sur la victime
c'est la question de quels sont les
moyens que l'agresseur a mis en oeuvre
qui doit être posée et la loi le dis
très clairement
et souvent on détourne la loi par cette
histoire de consentement on voit bien
qu'on est quand même encore très loin
très loin de ce qui est nécessaire pour
vraiment pouvoir avoir les moyens de
protéger les femmes
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat avec jean pierre
fabre bernadac qui est à l'origine de la
fameuse tribune des généraux avec jean
yves camus qui est politologue
spécialisé dans l'extrême droite et dans
les mouvements extrêmes carling à
l'acteur au ski et géopolitologue
également et david guiraud le
porte-parole jeunesse but la france a
soumis ce jean pierre fabre bernadac
j'imagine la réponse que vous allez le
faire mais je vous pose quand même la
question
cette tribune ça n'est pas un appel aux
poules ça n'est pas un appel à la
sédition pour vous alors écoutez je vais
reprendre le texte parce que c'est plus
simple on n'a pas à se disputer à partir
du moment où on est d'accord sur les
termes il y a dans la dernière partie
ceci par contre si rien n'est entrepris
le laxisme continuera à se répandre
inexorablement dans la société
provoquant au final une explosion à
l'intervention de nos camarades active
dans une écoute et bien dans une mission
c'est une mission donc il n'est pas
question que ce soit nous qui faisions
quoi que ce soit c'est une mission qui
doit de l'émission c'est le pouvoir
politique qui donne les missions
périlleuses en plus si c'était nous qui
la fusion
pourquoi on irait parler de mission
périlleuse donc déjà la solution de
putsch est ridicule et ridicule
deuxièmement je vais vous dire ça se
voit j'ai 70 balais c'est pas moi qui
vais demain prendre un casque lourd
gilet pare balles et une kalachnikov ou
un famas donc série c'est d'autant plus
ridicule ce que j'ai voulu dire est très
simple et ça ce jeu on va revenir à ce
problème de la constitution et de
l'article 36 ce qui est important à
savoir c'est qu'il ya trois forces de
catégories dans le pays
la première force de catégorie c la
gendarmerie départementale et la police
nationale
la deuxième force de catégorie c la
gendarmerie mobile est la troisième
force de quatre coeurs oui parce qu'il y
en a trois dans quelques années à une
troisième qui peut intervenir en cas de
quoi en cas d'état d'urgence et nous
sommes dans l'état d'urgence les
opérations sentinelles fait partie de ça
ou l'état de siège
la différence entre les deux est temps
que l'état d'urgence c'est de pouvoir
cyril calame à l'état de siège c'est le
pouvoir militaire
donc il y à cette possibilité c'est ça
que je veux dire ce que je veux dire
c'est n'en arriverons pas là c'est à
dire que on prend mal être et on fait
exactement l'inversé
ce que je veux dire c'est il ne faut pas
qu'ils aient de guerre civile et moi on
me dit que je veux la guerre civile
c'est exactement comme si je vous disais
par exemple je disais un ami attention
tu vas prendre la voiture conduit
calmement parce que sinon tu peux avoir
un accident
et donc on va me dire que je veux
l'accident c'est ridicule
je crois qu'il faut vraiment qu'on parle
la même langue française et qu' on
puisse comprendre ça moi je c'est un cri
d'alarmé
je ne veux pas en arriver là donc je dis
aux gens attention examiner la situation
elle est grave nous à moi j'ai des
retombées j'étais dans la gendarmerie
j'ai des retombées de partout elle est
grave et je peux en donner des exemples
donc je crois qu'il faut prendre
conscience de ça voilà ce que je veux
dire
j'arrive camus on a accusé marine le pen
d'être tombé dans le piège de s'être des
masques et d'avoir fait la preuve
en soutenant cette tribune
deux au fond d'eux d'avoir montré
qu'elle est elle n'était pas si
démocrate que cela est ce que est ce que
vous l'entendez comme ça vous aussi moi
j'aime pas le langage de démasquer
quelque chose qui révèle le vrai visage
de etc
je pense que marine le pen fait une
erreur en se précipitant dans le soutien
à cette tribune ne serait ce que pour
une raison simple et les candidates à
l'élection présidentielle elle est
donnée ou second tour de l'élection
présidentielle il ya effectivement une
possibilité pour elles c'est d'appeler
celles et ceux qui partagent les
constats énoncées dans cette tribune à
se rendre aux urnes et à voter
d'ailleurs constate une chose elle l'a
dit elle n'a pas dit exactement je me
range à votre constat et je suis
d'accord avec vous elle a dit j'ai
l'hymne que j'ai vu votre tribune et je
vous demande de me suivre
ce qui si si en fait que au fond c'est
elle qui considère qu'elle a le
leadership les victimes
ça veut pratiquement dire on écoute et
vous représentez moins que moi et c'est
moi qui vais porter ces valeurs-là lors
de l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22
voilà ensuite je pense qu'effectivement
dans le processus de dédiabolisation
puisque tout est scruté à la loupe c'est
pas nécessairement ce qui l a fait mieux
que de que de soutenir cette tribune qui
donneront l'impression quand même tout
ça est un peu récupéré politiquement
alors qu'encore une fois il ya dans la
constitution
deux articles qui se rapporte à des
situations exceptionnelles roux vient
d'en parler un article l'article 36 sur
l'état de siège qui n'a pour l'instant
jamais été appliquée il faut d'ailleurs
rappeler sur la question de l'état de
siège que l'état de siège et
en vigueur pour une durée limitée que si
on veut le prolonger il est prolongé
sous le contrôle du parlement
caroline galette perros à propos de
marine le pen précisément moi je trouve
que je je je je vais vous dire je trouve
que c'est le sait le pouvoir actuel en
place qui aurait dû au contraire
comprendre l'importance de cette de ceux
de ce message la vitalité justement de
la parole militaire et c'est une bonne
chose parce que nos soldats ne se sont
aussi des citoyens nos soldats ont mis
effectivement leur vie au bout de leurs
fusils pour le pays
ils ont un niveau de conscience ils ont
une expérience ils ont une capacité à
analyser les situations qui est
importante et je trouve que ce qui est
très dommage c'est la manière dont le
pouvoir s'est crispé parce qu'il est
dans un déni
assez assez lourd quand même de la
réalité sécuritaire du pays et donc
cherche à immédiatement faire taire des
gens qui finalement explique que ils ont
comme d'autres comme des comme des
milliers des dizaines de milliers
peut-être des centaines de milliers ou
des millions de citoyens français le
sentiment que sécuritairement le pays va
mal et qu'on n'est pas tout à fait en
contrôle de cette détérioration
voilà pour diverses raisons pour divers
abandon pour divers postes et c'est tout
un délitement effectivement le
délitement est un très bon mot c'est un
délitement de de la nation qui se
produit alors on l'appelle de plein de
mots différents du séparatisme du
communautarisme
oui il ya de tout ça et c'est très
dangereux et je pense moi j'ai vraiment
interpréter cette tribune com justement
voilà un constat et attention parce
qu'il ne faut surtout pas arriver un
moment où effectivement n'aura plus que
l'armée pour réagir
voilà que même si c'est prévu par les
textes même si ça se fait sous le sous
la houlette évidemment et sous la
direction et sous l'impulsion politique
sous la décision politique c'est évident
mais les armées sont un élément de la
nation ne peut pas peut pas juste dire
c'est la grande muette c'est le devoir
de réserve d'ailleurs on définit jamais
véritablement et et se priver de cette
conscience de ce niveau de conscience de
cette partie là de la population qui est
partie prenante du corps de la nation
david guiraud je disais le france a
soumises a réagi a été assez promptes à
réagir à ces tribunes ailleurs à la fois
pour dénoncer marine le pen mais aussi
pour reprocher au gouvernement de ne pas
avoir réagi plus vite
oui mais parce que quand j'entends
l'explication de monsieur fabre bernadac
jeudi mais on va on va être pris pour
des imbéciles pendant combien de temps
cet
parce que déjà les arguments de monsieur
bernadac ont changé dit pas du tout les
mêmes choses qu'eux ya trois semaines
les trois semaines il était là tambour
battant il expliquait qu'il fallait
absolument intervenir en fait il était
dans dans cette espèce de flou mais le
voilà monsieur monsieur fabre bernadac
était un militaire le voilà devenu
linguiste maintenant alors il nous
explique que les mots c'est pas
exactement ça qu'il voulait dire c'est
un rétropédalage jeu en français en fait
ça s'appelle comme ça et moi je vous dis
juste que à partir du moment où vous
avez des gens qui sont des militants
identifiés dangereux je pense à monsieur
piquemal bien des signataires de la
tribune de monsieur fabre bernadac
il a été radié de l'armée ce monsieur et
il milite avec des gens notamment
monsieur renaud camus qui eux y est le
théoricien de la théorie du grand
emplacement cette théorie là a inspiré
le terroriste en nouvelle zélande
qui a tué 50 morts en attaquant des
mosquées brendon tarente qu'inspirait au
6e génération identitaire il se sait
tamoul à ce terrorisme cela avant de
faire son attentat il a sorti un
manuscrit qui s'appelle le grand
remplacement c'est à dire le nom de la
théorie de renaud camus avec lequel
flirt les amis de monsieur fabre
bernadac donc à un moment il faut qu'on
se réveille quoi quand je veux dire je
veux bien comprendre qu'on puisse avoir
un débat sur l'aspect sécuritaire mais
il faut arrêter
il faut arrêter de se faire prendre pour
des imbéciles monsieur fabre bernadac
nous dit qu'il veut lutter contre le
délitement de la société comme quoi les
gens sont en train de se séparer
mais en même temps dans son site ici des
gens qui veulent séparer les noirs et
les blancs qui sont pour l'apartheid
je veux dire il ya un moment il faut se
réveiller il nous dit qu'il veut pas la
guerre civile mais en même temps il
donne la parole sur son site dans un
article d'il ya quelques jours un
général qui dit vas y avoir des bavures
si on n'intervient il y aura le bruit
des bottes ce sera le nôtre
enfin je veux dire réveillez vous les
habitants et c'est pour ça que je moi ce
que je critique principalement c'est la
mollesse des organisations républicaines
c'est la mollesse du gouvernement c'est
la mollesse c'est à dire des gens qui se
disent bon c'est un problème parmi tant
d'autres vous vous trouvez pas qu'il ya
un problème déjà qu' on est instaurée
comme interlocuteur légitime monsieur
fabre bernadac à partir d'une tribune
qui aujourd'hui a réuni à peine 2 % des
militaires à la retraite de ce pays 2 %
vous mettez 100 personnes dans une salle
deux types d'extrême droite qui disent
oui au fait j'ai fait une pétition
d'extrême droite et on va se mettre à se
dire que toute la salle est extrêmement
mais non et d'ailleurs je pense que les
militaires ne veulent pas de ça ils ne
veulent pas être mêlé à ces questions là
et je suis pour que les militaires
puissent se faire revenir leur malaise
par exemple moi je trouve que
l'opération sentinelle c'est une
catastrophe la manière dont on traite
les militaires ils sont mal logées
maltraités dans les opérations
extérieures c'est pareil manque de
moyens tout comme les policiers on peut
avoir un débat un débat démocratique là
dessus mais il n'empêche que les
militaires aujourd'hui ils ont aussi le
droit de vote
on peut se la montée qu'il y ait plus de
vote extrême et qu'ils ont le droit de
vote
ils sont pas dénués droit les militaires
par contre ils ont des obligations celle
d'être un peu modéré et celle même parce
qu'ils sont fonctionnaires et donc que
c'est un engagement tout au long de la
vie
et ben de faire attention dans leur
expression c'est exactement la raison
pour laquelle monsieur piquemal qui est
un des signataires de ce texte a été
radié parce qu'il était là alors il
faisait des manifestations contre les
migrants en disant des choses horribles
au microphone bas où il a été radié
il n'est pas digne de conserver son
statut il n'est pas digne de conserver
sa carte d'officiers je suis désolé
c'est pas ça les honneurs conso
militaires dans le pays
donc il faut des sanctions des sanctions
fortes pour dire que justement ça ne se
fait pas dans un pays démocratique parce
que dans un pays démocratique et ben
c'est pouvoir politique qui règne pas le
pouvoir militaire voilà est ce que veut
faire monsieur permet à dax et préparé
ça et je vous le dis je m'arrête pas
parce que je suis un peu bavard aux
etats unis les gens qui ont envoyé le
capitole avant d'envahir le capitalisme
c'est la même chose
il faisait des îles et des pétitions ils
se comptaient il disait maintenant on
veut pas la guerre civile on veut pas
testé moi j'observe que dans toutes les
situations historiques l'extrême droite
avant de passer à l'action et de manière
violente se comptent elles se comptent
elles testent elle teste des limites
c'est comme les enfants de 3 ans
l'extrême droite si à un moment vous lui
dites pas ce tome ils vont continuer et
moi je je je m'oppose à ce processus là
qui de la même manière qu'il a été
enclenchée aux états unis est
aujourd'hui enclenchée en france et
monsieur fabre barman en est un des
avatars
alors jean pierre fabre d'albert dadas
réponse oh là là j'en ai beaucoup
aujourd'hui je vais essayer d'aller vite
d'abord vous savez c'est pour les
accusations je commence à trouver un peu
ça sature ans ce genre de choses mais je
vais répondre
vous savez c'est l'homme qui a vu
l'homme qui a vu l'homme qui a vu l'ours
voilà où on en est c'est à dire que on
me dit il ya monsieur untel qui a dit
ceci donc qui est copain avec monsieur
untel qui a dit ceci qui lui même est
copain avec monsieur apple qui a dit
ceci je vous ai laissé parler donc ok
très bien c'est vrai tu raisonnement
ensuite le terrorisme de l'extrême
droite c'est vrai que j'en sais rien
d'abord moi je ne considère pas comme
être l'extrême droite je me considère
comme patriotes alors si vous voulez le
classer extrême droite pouvait menacer
ce que vous voulez j'ai vu comme un bouc
l'acier mais c'est vrai que l'extrême
gauche et et d'une patte d'un pacifisme
extraordinaire s'est jamais l'extrême
gauche ne va utiliser une batte de
base-ball ou d'un cocktail molotov au
wat mais ça
ça c'est pas le plus important le plus
important c'est que c'est quand même
vous grâce à vous et je vous en remercie
que nous avions ou que nous nous avons
réussi à faire monter cette tribune
parce que s'il n'y avait pas eu ce
monsieur mélenchon comme l'a très bien
dit madame ben je pense que on n'en
serait pas là donc je vous remercie
je vous remercie parce que grâce à vous
grâce à ce jour et non non laissez-moi
terminé grâce à vous on a en a on a
réussi à faire ceci
ensuite je ne savais pas que les
insoumis connaissait aussi bien les
militaires je pensais pas que parmi les
militaires il y avait autant de
pourcentage de gens qui votent pour les
a soumis à priori puisque vous avez fait
tout à tout un baratin je dirais sur
l'art mais il ya un minimum
vous savez que l'armée en règle générale
depuis 25 ou 30 ans ou 40 ans que ces
gens qui ont signés sont des gens qui se
taisent et bien au bout de trente ou
quarante ans on prend l'habitude de se
taire alors pour que ces gens aient eu
le courage de signer et je peux vous
dire que c'est pas facile
eh bien ça pour qu'ils en avaient gros
sur la patate et que par conséquent
c'est quelque chose qui est beaucoup
plus important que vous le dites et j'en
ai deux preuves
je vais vous en donner une comment se
fait-il que si on ne représente rien
comme vous dites
le chef d'état major des armées et film
est spécifique
comment se fait-il que si on ne
représente rien le chef d'état major de
l'armée de terre
c est pris sa plume pour pour dire à ce
procès soldats attention il faut pas
aller jusque là il faut pas prendre ce
genre de message il faut être distant de
ce genre de message tout en
reconnaissant qu on a parfaitement le
droit de le faire d'ailleurs
vous pensez bien que le linge et les
généraux des généraux ou n'aurait pas
fait ça s'il ne savait pas que derrière
mais s'il ne savait pas que derrière
l'armée danse dans une dans une part
importante je ne veux pas dire la
majorité jeudi dans une part important
est consciente de ça et je peux même
vous dire plus
ça je peux vous le dire c'est que ça
discute énormément de la lettre dans les
milieux d'activ c'est pour ça que les
généraux ont fait ces deux lettres
alors il n'y a pas que dans l'est
mieux d'actifs qu'on discute de votre
tribune il ya aussi ce sondage je
voulais pas qu'on termine ce débat sans
l'aborder sondage louis harris
interactive pour lci dans les coups l'on
découvre que 58% des français
soutiennent les militaires ayant signé
que 84 % pensent que la venue violence
augmente de jour en jour que 73 % sont
d'accord pour dire que le pays se délite
que les deux tiers je me j'arrive pas à
me relire sur celui là mais surtout et
c'est ça le le chiffre le plus important
c'est que 49% des français penseraient
que l'armée devrait intervenir pour
garantir l'ordre
même sans être sollicité par le
gouvernement alors voilà un sondage qui
est quand même assez étonnant mais sur
lequel on peut effectivement émettre des
réserves
alors jean yves camus
vous l'avez lu ce sondage qu'est ce que
vous avez pensé il ya effectivement des
problèmes de méthodologie qui tiennent à
la taille de l'échantillon une fois
qu'on a fait soustraction des personnes
interrogées qui disent ne pas savoir de
quoi on parle
ça c'est le premier point second point
c'est que pour ma part en admettant que
ce sondage est une une validité ou vue
de sa méthodologie jeu les looks plus
tôt j'ai eu plutôt ce pourcentage
d'approbation comme un pourcentage
d'approbation des constats plutôt qu'un
pourcentage d'approbation de
l'éventuelle intervention non sollicitée
par le pouvoir politique de l'armée
active
voilà c'est une assez vieilles constante
dans notre pays qu'à un moment donné une
partie de la population parce qu'elles
sont effectivement nous sommes dans une
situation compliquée se disent
finalement le dernier recours c'est
l'armée oui après tout pourquoi pas je
me souviens qu'il ya déjà quelques
quelques dizaines d'années
il y avait dans les journaux des
tribunes disons si ça continue il faudra
y envoyer l'armée
une fois qu'on a dit ça
est ce que finalement mise au pied du
mur et voyant la réalité d'une
intervention militaire
la totalité de ceux qui ont répondu
positivement à ce sondage serait heureux
du résultat j'en suis absolument pas
persuadé parce qu'encore une fois ce qui
manque dans tout cela c'est de dire
qu'on n'a pas épuisé toutes les voies de
recours
on n'a pas épuisé toutes les voies de
recours parce que le politique peut se
saisir davantage se saisir mieux de la
situation parce qu'il ya quand même la
démocratie qui permet d'exprimer un vote
parce qu'on a parlé tout à l'heure du
volet policier de la répression des
incivilités la délinquance paye
également les questions du volet
judiciaire sur lequel il ya me
semble-t-il beaucoup de discussions à
avoir donc je crois qu'il faut prendre
de ce sondage avec énormément de pain
cette voie là et puis rappeler aussi que
en europe occidentale
il n'y a pas eu de bouche militaire y a
pas eu d'intervention militaire depuis
très très longtemps le dernier cas
recensé ces 1982 avec 7 c'est arrivé aux
cortès du colonel thegero qui monte à la
tribune et qui bouclent les portes des
cortès en disant voilà il ya dans
certaines provinces des divisions qui
bouge je vous laisse pas sortir tant que
la situation n'est pas réglée et puis
dans la nuit et cette intervention du
roi en carlos et qui on a reproché
beaucoup de choses mais qui ce soir-là a
fait preuve de courage et de lucidité
et puis on voit que la chose se
dégonfler que et que ce putsch ne ne
prend pas voilà parce qu'on a
aujourd'hui une société dans laquelle on
a les réseaux sociaux dans lesquels on à
la société civile etc l on a
naturellement des des contre-pouvoirs et
il me semble véritablement que les
français n'accepteraient ces deux
solutions pour de vrai et je dis
revoyant le matin quand ils se
réveillent l'armée dans la rue il ne
l'accepterai véritablement qu'encore de
délitement absolue bien au-delà de ce
que nous connaissons
ce qui ne veut pas dire que la situation
soit rose
david guiraud sur ce sondage oui bah
écoutez ça je voulais déjà dit sur 1600
personnes nous en avait que six ans
qu'ils sont au courant de vraiment de ce
don qui parle donc encore une fois on
discute d'un sondage ou même pas la
moitié des gens ont vraiment lui la
tribune c'est à dire vous avez 38 % des
gens qui savent de quoi de quoi il est
question
mais qui n'ont même pas forcément lui
toute la tribu donc on discute en
brassant du vent avec ce sondage je vous
le dis maintenant que y ait un débat
dans la société sur l'armée et observer
c'est souvent des réflexions qu'on
entend souvent à faudra envoyer l'armée
dans les quartiers de ce débat il existe
mais le propre de ce débat c'est d'être
un d un débat entre citoyens à débat
politique vous allez même des
responsables politiques moi je le
déplore mais qu'on appelait à l'armée
dans les quartiers ça complètement
délirant mais c'est le propre des
responsables politiques les responsables
politiques qu'ils sont élus par les gens
me lis les militaires sont pas élus et
la question de fond elle est là
quant à monsieur fabre bernadac qui nous
explique qu' il y a une majorité
silencieuse dans l'armée mais c'est
tellement facile de dire ça parce que
c'est invérifiable
moi aussi je peux dire mais vous savez
je suis au courant je discute avec les
militaires il ya eu mal vous savez il ya
une majorité silencieuse dans l'armée
qui voudrait que la france a soumis au
gouvernement
c'est ma parole contre la vôtre voilà
donc qu'est ce qui nous reste à part
traiter les gens de menteur c'est trop
facile ce procédé là vous savez moi je
pense qu'il ya des militaires qui qui
qui vote qui votent à l'extrême droite
qui votent à droite y en a qui vote à
gauche il ya une tradition militaire
regardez par exemple les bataillons de
chasseurs alpins sedan le plateau des
glières des traditions de résistance une
tradition républicaine c'est beaucoup de
militaires qui ne veulent pas et je le
répète qu'ils ne veulent pas être
associés à la tribune de monsieur
bernadac qui rassemble 2 % des
militaires à la retraite de ce pays 2%
c'est rien c'est rien et est derrière
les effets de communication nous dit il
je suis en contact avec mais vous êtes
en contact avec qui en fait rage veut
dire donner les noms si c'est comme ça
ou alors ne les dit pas si ces gens
veulent pas être exposés mais ne ne fait
pas semblant que vous contrôlez les
réseaux de l'armée entière et c'est
encore c'est une technique bien connue
de rhétorique de rue
j'en connais deux trois moi aussi j'ai
des amis me taire moi aussi j'ai des
proches qui sont militaires le monsieur
fabre bernadac et qui d'ailleurs qui
sont pas d'accord avec moi je ne
faut pas leur parole voilà s'ils veulent
parler le fond ils sont grands ils n'ont
pas besoin de vous pour le faire et donc
à partir de ce moment là il faut avoir
un débat sur qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
des normes et moi ya ya ya aucun
problème majeur encore une fois je vous
ai dit la france insoumise et
probablement la seule organisation
politique qui pendant la campagne
présidentielle a fait venir des généraux
de la marine et enfin des amiraux du
goût et des généraux à des colloques
pour établir un livret sur la défense a
été sorti par l'institut de la défense
de sueur l'indépendantisme français mr
david biraud parce qu'il n'aurait très
peu de temps et je voudrais donner la
parole à caroline gallargues terros et à
jean pierre fabre bernadac qui n'ont pas
eu sur ce sujet alors sur ce sondage
caroline
mais sur ce sondage moi je pense que ça
traduit une inquiétude je pensais que je
suis je suis vraiment de la vie de
monsieur camus et je pense que ça
traduit une véritable inquiétude il
faudrait arrêter de 2 à la mitraillette
d'essayer de détruire à la mitraillette
rhétorique je veux dire naturellement
d'essayer de 2,2 deniers de dénier la
pertinence et la réalité de la situation
sécuritaire de notre pays
donc moi je pense surtout qu'il faut il
est très très très urgent que les
autorités politiques actuellement en
place dans ce pays prenne la mesure de
cette situation ne ne se gardent de
l'utiliser à des fins électorales et
essai de la traiter parce que c'est
comme ça qu'on évite ce dont on parle
dans cette tribune ces cas extrêmes ces
cas dangereux c'est que personne n'a
envie de voir et c4 les français ne
veulent pas en revanche les français
voudraient bien vivre en paix
tranquillement sans être agressé sans
être molestés sans être angoissé tout le
temps de savoir et pas seulement dans
les banlieues de savoir ce qu'il va bien
pouvoir leur arrivée à eux leurs enfants
ça se passe en plein paris se passe tout
près de chez moi
voilà donc il faut juste traiter les
problèmes quoi traiter les problèmes et
ça a essayé bien sûr il ya aussi la
question judiciaire
il ya tout à reprendre il ya tout à
reprendre 7
la série continue à y est en très
mauvais état
alors jean pierre fabre bernadac oui
alors si vous permettez d'abord juste
avant un mot avant de sondage pour
répondre à monsieur kinois qui a lu
place d'armes
mais il n'a pas tout lui c'est à dire il
ya des choses qu'il n'a pas dites alors
je vais vous donner maintenant ma
réponse à marine
voilà ce que je dis notre site n'a pas
pour but d guye et ses membres vers un
parti chaque adhérent possède le
discernement nécessaire pour trouver
seule sa voix politiques
il est pour le moins maladroit
d'effectuer une opération de racolage
pour des besoins électoraux ça c'était
la première chose que je vous dire
maintenant moi je pense que monsieur est
certainement à même de nous donner des
éléments sur la france insoumise et
toutes les structures qui vont avec et
je ne dénie pas ça alors qu'il ne me
délit pas le droit qui me dénie pas le
droit de bien connaître quand même les
militaires je pense que j'ai quand même
une une certaine propension à mieux les
cerner que vous parce que je les connais
je dirais deux de l'as rome gers
jusqu'au quai jusqu'au casque lourd et
ça c'est très différent
dernier point si vous permettez je
voudrais dire que qu'est-ce que pour moi
il manque à la france trois choses il
lui manque aujourd'hui de retrouver un
idéal et pas les iphone ou où les ou
twitter ou autre la deuxième chose c'est
l'exemplarité
c'est à dire que je crois que si ces
gens ont dit à un moment donné 49% qu'
on ne pouvait se passer des politiques
savent eux ça voulait pas dire qu'il
voulait un putsch ça voulait dire on n'a
plus confiance dans le politique et nous
l'exemplarité on essaye je ne dis pas
que tous les tous les militaires sont
exemplaires
mais un militaire quand il fait une
marche commando avec ses hommes un
officier est bien quand il averti
les gars vous mettez 25 kilos sur le dos
je peux vous dire une chose c'est que
lui l'année 35 parce qu'il sait que
évidemment avec le caractère français il
y en a bien un qui va dire et mon
lieutenant laïque amiens vous de kilos
et ce moment là il lui dit qu'il
prononça qui regarde bien
ce type là après je peux vous dire
qu'ils vous suivent jusqu'au bout c'est
ça l'exemplarité et c'est ça qui manque
aux politiques et c'est ça que nous
avons et la dernière points alors je
vais le dire de deux manières de la
manière militaire
ça s'appelle une paire de couilles et de
la manière civile ça s'appelle du
courage ces trois choses cédé 3 chose
qui manque dans notre pays
et si notre pays retrouve et ça je pense
que en effet on n'aurait pas besoin de
suspendre comme et psp de damoclès la
notion de guerre civile voilà cette
notion que je réfute et que j'exècre
parce que ça ça veut dire comme je le
dis à la fin des milliers de morts
je vous remercie tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce débat on l'a largement
dépassé le temps merci merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]